we're told that jalen modeled the
following relationships about their bus
ride so there's three functions here we
have their inputs and we have their
outputs so function p the input is the
time the bus arrives given as lowercase
b and the output is the probability that
jalen gets to work on time so p of b all
right
function n
the input is the time the bus arrives
given as k
and the output is the number of people
at the bus stop when the bus arrives so
it's the number of people at the bus
stop as a function of the time the bus
arrives
and then t centimeters of precipitation
the input is centimeters of
precipitation per hour x and this gives
us the time the bus arrives as a
function of that precipitation
interesting
now they ask us which of the following
composed functions makes sense in this
context so we have to pick two so pause
this video and see if you can have a go
at it before we work through it together
all right now let's look at this first
composite function here so let's see
what's going on one way to think about
this is we're taking x
we are inputting that into our function
t
that will then output t of x and then
we're trying to input that into our
function
p
which would then output p of the input
which is t
of x now does this make sense
x is the centimeters of precipitation
per hour
t of x is the time the bus arrives as a
function of that so we're going to take
the time the bus arrives is that a
reasonable input into p
let's see function p the input is the
time the bus arrives so this makes a lot
of sense we're taking this which is the
time the bus arrives and we're using
that as an input into p which is exactly
what we want to be the input into p and
so we have p as a function of the time
the bus arrives which is then a function
of the centimeters of precipitation per
hour
so i like
this choice right over there
now let's look at the next choice p as a
function of n of k
let's see so we're taking k
which is the time the bus arrives
we're inputting it into the function
n
which then outputs n of k
now the output here n of k is the number
of people at the bus stop when the bus
arrives
and then we're trying to put that into
our function p
now does that make sense to take the
number of people at the bus stop when
the bus arrives and input it into a
function that expects as the input the
time the bus arrives
that does not make sense p wants as an
input time the bus arrives but we're
giving it the number of people at the
bus stop so i do not like this choice
now let's look at choice
c
so t of x right over here we already
know that outputs the time the bus
arrives which we know is a legitimate
input into function n function n takes
the time the bus arrives and as a
function uh and based on that input it
gives you the number of people at the
bus stop so this makes sense so i like
this choice as well so i'm guessing i
won't like choice d but let me validate
that so p of b
so this is going to give us the
probability that jalen gets to work on
time and then we're inputting that into
this function t that's expecting
centimeters of precipitation per hour
well that's not going to work out you're
trying to take a probability and you're
inputting it into a function that
expects centimeters of precipitation per
hour so i would rule that one out as
well so i like a and c